let's see if we can simplify this
expression here so the first thing that
it looks like we would want to do is
let's see we don't have any like terms
that we can combine here and here like
terms would be terms that have the same
the same variables raised to the same
degree so for example if this was a x
squared y to the third then we could
combine them but it's not and we have
nothing like that over here so let's
distribute this 15xy onto here first so
15xy times negative 4 well that's going
to be negative
60 xy i just multiply the 15 times the
negative 4 to get the negative 60 and we
still have the x y
and then we have 15xy times negative 3 x
squared y to the third so let's think
about how this is going to happen we're
going to have 15 times negative 3 which
is negative 45
then we're going to have x times x
squared which is x to the third power
then we're going to have y times y to
the third power which is y to the fourth
power just adding the exponents you
could view this as x to the first times
y to the first so we did that
then we have 15xy times 2y 15 times 2 is
30
and then x there's nothing to multiply
the x by so we just keep leaving the x
there and then y times y is y squared
so we've done that and we're going to
add all of this business to that stuff
over there so we have that added to
plus this parentheses really doesn't do
anything we're just adding all of this
stuff so plus 4 x y squared
minus 20 x to the third y to the third
plus 70. now let's see if there are any
like terms that we can combine
so first of all we have this negative
60xy are there any other xy x to the
first times y to the first is x to the
third why no no no no no other things
that it can combine with so we'll just
leave it there
so we have negative 60
x y
and then let's look over here negative
45 x to the third y
to the fourth so is there any place
where we can combine that x to the third
y to the fourth so nope
nope this is x to the third y to the
third so that doesn't work either so we
just have to keep that
negative 45
x to the third
y to the 4th power
and then we have
30xy squared so we have anything to
combine it with well we have an xy
squared here so we have 30xy squareds
and we can have we can add another 4xy
squareds over here so these are like
terms just the coefficient is different
they're both they're both something
multiplied by xy squared so we can add
the sum things 30 plus 4 gives us 34
x
y squareds and then we have this
negative 20 x to the third y to the
third nothing to combine that with
negative 20 x to the third y to the
third and then there's nothing to
combine the 70 with so then we just get
plus 70 and we are done